[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
والعفو الدوليه تطالب بمراقبه محاكمات
المتظاهرين
محتجو ايران يحتفلون بهزيمه النظام بعد
خساره منتخب بلدهم امام امريكا في كاس
العالم
[تصفيق]
وفي المونديال الصقور الخضر تتطلعه لحجزي
بطاقه في ثمن النهائي امام المنتخب
المكسيكي
اذا المشاهدين سنبدا بالتطورات في باكستان
قتل ثلاثه اشخاص بهجوم الانتحاري استهدف
دوريه للشرطه الباكستانيه جنوب غربي
البلاد الشرطه ذكرت ان الهجوم والذي وقع
في مدينه كويته تسبب ايضا باصابه ثمانيه
وعشرين شخصا من بينهم 15 ضابطا بالشرطه
طبعا مصادر المحليه تحدث عن اعلان حركه
طالبان باكستان مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم الذي
ياتي بعد يومين فقط من اعلان الحركه
استئناف الهجمات ضد القوات الحكوميه دعونا
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنى من اسلام اباد مراسل العربيه
عبد الرحمن المزيني اهلا بك عبد الرحمن
بدايه اي معلومات جديده حول هذا الاستهداف
نعم
ساره هذه نائب مفتش شرطه مدينه
من بينهم شرطي وامراه وطفل من المره اضافه
الى جرح 25 اخرين من بين هؤلاء 20 شرطيا
ال- ال- وفقا تقرير الاوليه الشرطه
الباكستانيه فان مهاجما انتحاريا يقود
عربه
همم اقترب من القافله او ال- ال- الحافله
التي تقول العناصر الشرطه اثناء توجهها
للمشاركه في همم فرق التطعيم تطعيم ضد شلل
الاطفال اقامه بتفجير العبوه الناسفه لدى
افترابه من هذه الحافله وهو ما ادى الى
انحرافها الى ااا الى هاويه مجاوره من
الطريق وهوما ادى الى هذا العدد من الجرحى
في صفوف الشرطه اضافه الى دمار المركبه
ومركبتين اخرىين همم كانت بالقرب من مكان
الهجوم حركه الطالبان باكستان اعلنت عن
مسؤوليه عن هذا الهجوم الانتحاري الذي يعد
الاول منذ اعلان الحركه انهاء وقفه اطلاق
النار مع ال- ال- الحكومه وقالت انه ياتي
ولكن قوي جدا رساله قويه في ما يبدو كيف
تقرا هذه العمليات تقرا على انها ربما
ستعزز من العوده الى نوع من التسويه او لا
العكس اصبحنا امام مواجهه الان وعوده لها
نعم هذا الهجوم هو ليس الاول من نوعه هناك
تصاعد في الهجمات منذ شهر سبتمبر الماضي
نعم قبل الاعلام قبل الاعلان حقيقه كان
هناك هجمات متفرقه همم منذ شهر سبتمبر
الماضي الى الى درجه ان مسؤولين في وزاره
الداخليه الباكستانيه في شهر اكتوبر قالوا
بان المفاوضاتنا حركه الطيران ووصلت الى
طريق محدود الى طريق مسدود لكن الاعلان
الحركه قبل يومين هو بمثابه همم اطلاق
النار اطلاق رصاصه الرحمه على هذه
المفاوضات همم هناك حاله من التنديد
والاستنكار هنا في الاوساط الباكستانيه
همم في همم اقليم خيبر الذي تقول في حركه
الانصاف الحكومه هناك مستشار رئيس الحكومه
الاقليميه دعا الحركه للعوده الى الطاوله
المفاوضات همم من المتوقع ان تشهد الايام
المقبله مزيدا من
يا جماعه التصعيديه لاسيما بعد اعلان
الحركه بان عملياتها سوف تتواصل ردا على
مقتل احد قيادها في شهر اغسطس الماضي في
افغانستان همم جراء عبوه ناسفه واتهمت
اجهزه الاستخبارات الباكستانيه بانها تقف
وراء مسؤوليه اغتيال القيادين فيها همم
هذه الهجمات تتزامن مع حاله من عدم
الاستقرار السياسي وهناك الان تولى قائد
الجيش الباكستاني الفريق اول عاصم منير
قياده الجيش وهناك ايضا همم كان هناك
زياره لوزيره الدوله الخارجيه افغانستان
تم البحث عن ملف الامني همم مع الحكومه
المؤقته التي تتدعمها حركه طالبان
افغانستان لا شك ان هذا الملف يقلق قد
صفات الباكستانيه اكثر من سبب افغانستان
مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن المزين شكرا
جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا ننتقل من باكستان الى ايران حيث
يتصاعدت حمله القمع ضد التظاهرات التي
طالت 26 محافظه ايرانيه منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه انه في حال عدم تعاون
السلطات الايرانيه مع وفد لجنه تقصي
الحقائق فانها ستكشف عن جوانب اوسع من
جرائمها كانت الخارجيه الايرانيه اعلنت ان
النظام لن يتعاون مع الاليات الدوليه
لحقوق الانسان منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه قالت في احدث تقرير لها ان عدد
ضحايا الانتفاضه الشعبيه ارتفع الى 48
قتيلا على الاقل بينهم 60 طفلا وتسع
وعشرون امراه بيد الامن الايراني التقرير
سجل ايضا مقتل 16 مواطنا وذلك في مختلف
انحاء ايران في الاسبوع الماضي فقط طبعا
غالبيتهم من المناطق الكرديه هذه
الاحصائيه بحسب مراقبين تظهر الحد الادنى
من الارقام اذا انها لا تشمل سوى الحالات
التي سجل باحث المنظمه وثائق كشهادات
الوفاه وايضا شهادات الطاقه الطبيه طبعا
من جهاتها منظمه العفو الدوليه دعت الدول
التي لها سفارات في ايران الى ارسال
مراقبين للمحاكمات الجاريه للمتظاهرين
المهددين بعقوبه الاعدام المنظمه اشارت
الى ان احدى هذه المحاكمات ستكون محاكمه
جماعيه نتحدث عن احد عشر شخصا طبعا هذه
المحاكمه الجماعيه تبدا اليوم في محافظه
باريس ما يعد انتهاكا صارخا للقانون
الدولي على حد او وصف المنظمه العفو
الدوليه عبرتها البالغ من تقرير تشير
لوجود اطفال بين المهددين بعقوبه الاعدام
في ايران طبعا محاكمات يرافقها استمرار
للقبض الامنيه على الارض دعونا مشاهدينا
نتابع صور للقوات الامنيه الايرانيه كيف
تنتشر في مدينه سقف على دراجات ناريه
نوم
شاه غربي
اطلاق نار ومظاهره ليليه عبر الشرفات
وايضا عبر النوافذ نتبعها معا
[موسيقى]
مزيد معنا من القاهره محمد عباس ناجي رئيس
تحرير مجله مختارات ايرانيه اهلا بك سيد
محمد بدايه كيف يمكن التعاطي مع النظام
الايراني في ظل رفضه للتعامل مع اللجنه
لجنه التحقيق
اهلا وسهلا بيكي السيده ميسون لا اعتقد
انه هناك خيارات كثيره امام المجتمع
الدولي للتعاطي مع النظام الايراني في هذا
الامر لانه
الى الان المجتمع الدولي بعد القوه
الدوليه دول الغربيه لديها مصالح مع
النظام وبالتالي خيرها الوحيد في هذا
التوقيت تحديدا هو فرض مزيد من العقوبات
غير مؤثره بشكل كبير على النظام الايراني
في المرحله الحاليه لذلك انا اتصور انه
الاهم او الضغوط الاهم التي يتعرض اليها
النظام هي الضغوط التي يفردها الشارع
الايراني الذي اثبت انه همم كسر حاجز
الخوف ولم يعد
يبالي كثيرا بالالي هي القمعيه التي
يتبعها النظام بدليل فرح جزء من المحتجين
بهزيمه المنتخب الايراني في مونديال كاس
العالم وخروجه من نهائيات
لانه
خاصه فيما يتعلق همم فرح من ف ما يعتبر من
قبل النظام الايراني العدو او الشيطان
الاكبر ولكن اسمح لي ان اتحدث عن التحركات
على الارض لانه بالرغم ما ذكرته من ضغوط
في الشارع وكسر حاجز الخوف انه النظام
يقوم بمحاكمات استمعنا الى ما يقال عن
محاكمه جماعيه ال 11 شخص من بينهم اطفال
ربما سيحكم عليهم بالاعدام هل السفارات
بالفعل قادره على التاثير على الارض او لا
هذه فقط فقاعات الان من قبل الغرب
عفوا يعني انا في اعتقادي حتى فيما يتعلق
بالاجراءات القمعيه التي يتبعها النظام هي
تثير ردود فعل رافضه طبعا من جانب المجتمع
الدولي لكن انا اتصور اي ضغوط من جانب
الدول الغربيه على ايران في المرحله
القادمه لن تؤثر كثيرا على همم الارض ربما
هناك محاوله هذه الدول تحاول استيعاب بعض
الضغوط الداخليه عليها لتغيير سياستها
النظام الايراني ربما تحاول همم استثمار
ما يحدث للضغط على النظام في ملفات اخرى
وهكذا لكن في كل الاحوال كما قلت من
البدايه المتغير الاهم هو قوه وتاثير
الاحتجاجات التي تحدث في الشارع انا اتصور
ان هذه هي التي تسبب الازمه الحقيقيه
للنظام الذي اصبح امام مواجهه او اختبار
صعب في المرحله الحاليه بسبب باستمرار
الاحتجاجات حتى الان وتجاوزها ربما
اقترابها من تجاوز الشهر السادس
همم كما ذكر سيدنا محمد قضيه الفرح بيفوز
العدو اا وحول هذه النقطه اا ابقى معي
ولكن لا شك بانه من المهم ان نظهر كيف همم
عبر الرئيس الامريكي جون بايدن عن سعادته
همم بعد ابلاغه طبعا بالنتيجه مباراه
المنتخب بين الامريكي والايراني ولكن
انتهت بفوز المنتخب الامريكي بهدف طبعا
بايضا من جهتها اثر على العوده الى المنصه
في حماسه زائده صارخا في الحشد الولايات
المتحده هدف وايران صفر طبعا تعليقا على
اقصاء المنتخب الامريكي لنظيره الايراني
من تصفيات كاس العالم في الدوحه قال بايضا
ان المنتخب الامريكي انتصر في مباراه لكره
القدم مع ايران مؤكدا انه اتصل بالمدرب
وايضا باللاعبين قبل المباراه
لتقديم الدعم لهم طبعا هذا بالنسبه لرد
فعل الولايات المتحده على لسان الرئيس
الامريكي اما في الداخل الايراني فقط
اطلقت الالعاب الناريه اطلقت الهدفات التي
صاحبها خروج الالاف من المحتاجين في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه للاحتفال بخساره منتخب
بلادهم امام نظيره الامريكيه ضمن منافسات
كاس العالم
المراقبون يرون ان احتفال الايرانيين
بخساره منتخب بلادهم امام العدو اللدود
لطهران يكشف عن حجم الفجوه بين النظام
والجماهير الايراني هذه الفجوه ادت الى
تعرض المنتخب الايراني لضغوط حكوميه
وشعبيه على حد سواء اثر الاحتجاجات كما
وقرر بعض الايرانيين تشجيع خصومهم طبعا
وفقا للمراقبين فان الكثير من الايرانيين
اعتبروا ان المنتخب الذي يلعب بكاس العالم
هو فريق النظام هو ليس المنتخب الوطني
الايراني معتبرين ان لاعبين المنتخب لم
يبدوا التعاطف الكافي مع المحتاجين دوما
وننتقل الى منطقه اذن في طهران حيث احتفلت
المنطقه في هزيمه منتخب الايراني امام
المنتخب الامريكي وفقا لهذه الصور
المتداوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا واكد نجمه كره القدم الايرانيه السابق
علي كريم اكد انه تعرض للتهديد بالقتل من
قبل السلطات الايرانيه وذلك لدعمه
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه وايضا لتضامنه مع
المتظاهرين الايرانيين الذين يحتجون ضد
النظام الايراني الحاكم علي كريم باتا
صوتا داعما للاحتجاجات الشعبيه من خارج
ايران وكشف خلال مقابله اجريت باللغه
الفارسيه عبر قناه ماكس امينه بموقع
يوتيوب كشف عن تعرض عائلته وايضا اصدقائه
المقربين للترهيب والمضايقه من قبل
الحكومه الايرانيه يعود الى ضيفه من
القاهره محمد عباس ناجي وهو رئيس تحرير
مجله ايرانيه للحديث عن هذه الحاله عاده
يكون محزن ان لا يقف انسان مع منتخب بلده
ولكن في الحاله الايرانيه هل يمكن القول
بانه مبرر
طبعا يعني انا لم استغرب كثيرا هذا الموقف
من جانب الايرانيين
لثلاثه اسباب رئيسيه السبب الاول كمان
ذكرتي في التقرير هو انه جزء من
الايرانيين استهجن موقف اللاعبين في
المباراه الثانيه امام ويلز عندما ردده
النشيد الوطني على خلاف ما حدث في
المباراه الاولى طبعا اللاعبون في النهايه
تعرضوا لضغوط وتهديدات من من النظام
باستهدافهم في حاله ما اذاكرروا هذا
الموقف لكن موقفهم بترديد النشيد الوطني
استهجان من جانب المحتاجين في الشارع
الايراني هذا من ناحيه اخرى همم الرمز كان
مهم جدا في الاحتجاجات الايرانيه ولو
لاحظنا المحتاجين اصبحوا يعتبروا هزيمه
الفريق الايراني في المونديال وخروجه من
النهائيات هي هزيمه للنظام وفشل لسياساته
وربما ايضا خروجه من السلطه في مرحله
بسبب
محمد المنتخب
بخساره المنتخب وما ربمانيكا بالنظام
الايراني ولكن ماذا عن الفرح بفوز
الولايات المتحده هل فعلا همم هي موقف
يمكن قراءته كموقف وتغير في عقليه
الايراني فيما يتعلق بالشيطان الاكبر او
لا
من البدايه
الايراني في العلاقه مع الخارج بشكل عام
سواء مع الولايات المتحده او الدول
الغربيه او العالم هناك جيل جديد يطلع
يظهر داخل ايران اصبح يتبنى سياسه
للانفتاح على الخارج ويرفج جدا السياسه
التي يتبناها النظام لكن دعينا اقول هو
انه هذا الموقف ربما هو رفض ل همم سياسه
النظام لانه ساعه الى تاسيس هذه المباراه
تحديدا قبل همم
ان تجرى على الارض لانه حاول تحشيد
الايرانيين خلفه قبل المباراه وبالتالي
يحاول تعزيز موقعه همم امام المحتجين قبل
هذه المباراه وبالتالي هزيمه المنتخب
الايراني امام المنتخب الامريكي همم كانت
رساله من جانب او الترحيب بها كان الرساله
من جانب المحتجين بانهم يرفضوا تاسيس
المونديال وتسييس المباراه وسياسات النظام
في التعامل مع الولايات المتحده مع الدول
الغربيه ومع العالم بشكل عام خلال المرحله
الحاليه من القاهره محمد عباس ناجي رئيس
تحرير مجله مختارات ايرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
البنتاجون يربوا عن قلقه من الهجوم
التركيه المرتقب في سوريا ويعلن تقليص
الدوريات المشتركه مع قصد سنبدا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره حذر
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
للجنرال بات رايدر حذر من ان اطلاق تركيا
عمليه بريه في سوريا قد يزعزع لاستقرار في
المنطقه وقد يعرض المكاسب التي تحققت في
الحرب على داعش للخطر داعيا انقر الى ضبط
النفس المتحدث باسم البنتاجون كشف عن ان
الجنود الامريكيين طبعا المنتشرين في شمال
شرق سوريا
مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
الوقت الحالي
عدد الدوريات المشتركه وكما ذكرت في بيان
الاسبوع الماضي مازلنا نشعر بقلق عميق اذا
التوتر المتصاعد في شمال سوريا والعراق
وتركيا لذلك نحن نحط على ضبط النفس وسط
التوترات في هذه المنطقه ان استمرار
الصراع وخاصه الغزو البري من شانه ان يعرض
للخطر المكاسب التي حققها العالم بشق
الانفس ضد داعش وسيؤدي الى زعزعه استقرار
المنطقه في المقابل اننا نعترف بمخاوف
تركيا الامنيه المشروعه فيما يتعلق
بالاعمال الارهابيه التي حدثت داخل حدودها
مع النظام السوري لتسليمه مواقعها ذلك
طبعا
مظلوم عبد عبده اكد ان موافقه على عوده
ساعه الحكوميه للنظام الى المناطق المهدده
بالعمليه التركيه مرتبط بالتواصل الى حال
سياسي مع دمشق كنا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان حدد اهداف العمليه البريه الجديده
وهي مناطق ترفعت منبج وكوباني شمال الرقه
طبعا في اطار هدفه الاوسع باقامه ما يطلق
عليه منطقه امنه بعمق 30 كلم على كل
المزيد معنا من برلين الباحث السياسي رستم
محمود اهلا بك سيد دارستم بدايه التصريحات
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بتقليس الدوريات
المشتركه هل يمكن القول بذلك بان الولايات
المتحده خدلت الاكراد مجددا وبالمقابل هو
ضوء اخضر لتركيا لبدا العمليه
يعني على العكس تقليص عدد الدوريات هو
استجابه لقرار من قبل قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي اعلنت انها اوقفت نسبيه
ان التعاون مع قوات التحالف الدولي
لمحاربه الارهاب ونسبيا ايضا اوقفت موضوع
محاربه داعش هذا الامر اي عدم التعاون
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه يؤدي بشكل تقليدي
لان تقلص الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكل
قوه التحالف من عملياتها العسكريه
ودوريتها على ارض
الواقعدوا النظر من اتخذ القرار عمليه
التقليس هل تعني ان الولايات المتحده خذلت
الاكراد او لا
عمليه التقليص لا تعني ذلك تماما عن طريق
استعداد للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا ميدانيا على ارض
الواقع بدون قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عمليه
التقليص تعني ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعترف بالدور الحيويه للقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وانها فعليا على ارض
الواقعه لا تستطيع الدخول في معركه في
مواجهه داعش بدون هذه القوه هذه بمثابه
رساله الى المؤسسات الاعمق داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالذات وزاره الخارجيه
والكونبريس والبيت الابيض تقول ازاله
الدفاع بان تخليكم عن اي ضغوط سياسيه
واضحه على تركيا
سوف تدفع الاعمال الميدانيه على ارض
الواقع الى هذا المساء الى المسار عدم
القدره على اطلاق دوريات وعلى متابعه
خلايا داعش المنتخب متبقيه سواء داخل
سوريا او داخل العراق لان هذه العمليه لا
لا لا تتعلق فقط بجهود عسكري تم وهو و ودى
هذه العمليه مستمره كما تفيد التقارير
الاستخباراتيه داعش ما تزال في منطقه
واسعه في الصحاري الموجوده بين سوريا
والتركيا ما زالت تملك خلايا وداعش ليست
مجرد تنظيم داعش هو عباره عن دعايه كبرى
تستخدم المقاتلين المختلفه انحاء العالم
وتغذي هذه كانت موجوده صحيح
عن حتى الورق المستخدمه فيما يتعلق بمخيم
الهول والدواعش الموجودين هناك وبالتالي
هي تعلم ذلك جيدا ان كان على الارض او همم
في القرارات
الرسميه هل هناك من رؤيه لما سيحدث لاحقا
في ما يتعلق بالتعاطي مع النظام السوري
وامكانيه هذه العوده وهمم بالنهايه
التنسيق المباشر واختلاف همم الرؤيا بهذا
الاطار
اعلني اجاوب على هذا السؤال بمستويين
عزيزتي المستوى الاول يقول ان المؤسسات
الامريكيه مختلفه فيما بينها بالنسبه
لقراءه الموضوع السوري عموما والموضوع في
شمال شرق سوريا وزاره الخارجيه تتصرف
بعقليه التوازنات السياسيه التي ماتزال
ترى تركيا كترف وحليف استراتيجي في الشرق
الاوسط وفي كامل العالم هناك اختلاف بين
هذه الرؤيه التي تتبناها وزاره الخارج
وبين رؤيه اجهزه الاستخبارات
الابيض يحاول ان يصنع نوع من التوازن بين
الطرفين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عقليتها المؤسساتها بسبب التوزيع لمستويات
السلطه في تلك البلاد لا تتصرف في جسم
واحد خصوصا وانه لا يوجد نتيجه كبرى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذه
المنطقه هناك نوع من الارتباط خلال
الامريكيتين جوابا على سؤالك هناك ثلاث
مستويات من رؤيه العلاقه مع النظام السوري
هناك رؤيه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي
تعتبر انه الاساس في المشكله انه هناك
مشكله سياسيه كبرى في سوريا تتعلق بطبيعه
النظام وان عوده النظام يعني عوده الدوله
وتانيا يجب الاتفاق على شكل دوله سوريا
الحديثه وعلى شكل النظام السياسي الذي يجب
ان يحكم لسوريا لا يمكن لاي شكل من
الاشكال العوده الى ما قبل الالفين واحد
2011 وهناك من العلاقه مع دمشق يتعلق بان
هذا النظام الحكم اللي دمشقيا كان هو
المخول حسب الامم المتحده والشرعيه وحسب
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه الدفاع عن الارض يجب
على هذا النظام اذا كان يعتبر نفسه هو ملك
سوريا
قال وزير الخارجيه السويد ان بلاده هو
فنلندا حق فتاه تقدم ملحوظ مع دوله فنلندا
حول ابرام اتفاق مع تركيا بشان انضمام
الدولتين لحلفي شمال الاطلسي تصريح الوزير
جاء خلال الاجتماع
الذي اكد من خلالها ان ملف الانضمام الى
حلف الناتو يحقق تقدما طبعا من جانب اخر
وفيما يتعلق بالتطورات في اوكرانيا قصفت
القوات الاوكرانيه محطه كهرباء في عده
هجمات على منطقه كورسكا الروسيه مما تسبب
في انقطاع جزء للتيار الكهربائي حاكم
المنطقه اوضح ان كان هناك اجمالا حوالي 11
عمليه اطلاق اصابه هذه المحطه للكهرباء
وانه لا توجد معلومات حتى الان عن اصابات
محتمله مضيفا ان هذا تسبب في انقطاع جزئي
في التيار الكهربائي في منطقتين وهما جزء
من كورس الروسيه
عن بالمقابل قال الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمارسالنسكي ان الوضع على خط
المواجهه لا يزال صعب حيث تحاول القوات
الروسيه تقدم في منطقتي الدومبس وخاركيف
دعونامي المتابعه
الكبيره لا يزال المحتلون يحاولون التقدم
في منطقه دوناتس والحصول على موطئ اقدم له
في منطقه لوكانس والانتقال الى منطقه
خاركه انهم يخططون لشيء ما في الجنوب
الاوكرانيون في منطقه الدومباس شرقيه
اوكرانيا تحديا جديدا طبعا هذا التحدي
يضاف الى مجمل تحديات فصل الشتاء في ساحه
المعركه في مواجهه روسيا وذلك بعدما غمر
مياه الامطار تحصينات وغمرت ايضا خنادق
الجنود المستخدمه كملاذ امن للاحتماء من
الصواريخ الروسيه
اقدم الجنود الاوكرانيين ليست على ارض
صلبه تحصينات وخنادق تغمرها المياه والوحل
ليضاف الى اختبار الصقيع اختبار قوه
التحمل
لكن الامر اصعب قليلا بسبب المطر والصقيع
انه مستنقع يمكنك رؤيته بنفسك لقد جفت
قليلا اليوم لكن لا باس نحن صامدون
مياه ووحل داخل خنادق الجنود الاوكرانيين
لكن لاحتماء بها امر لا تراجع عنه حتى ان
غابت الامكانات تبقى ملذا موحلا لكن امنا
من الصواريخ الروسيه
فقد جفت لكن مستوى المياه كان بهذا
الارتفاع كان مستنقعا بسبب المطار
استخدمنا دلاءا لازاله المياه
تحديات اختبار فصل الشتاء بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا قد يطول امادها
[موسيقى]
اما فوهه المدافع فلا تهدا لعل اصواتها
تصبح دافعا للاستمرار والبقاء على قيد
الحياه لمن هم اسفل خنادق الحرب
علي السمان العربيه
زياره دوله تستمر ثلاثه ايام يلتقي خلالها
نظيره الامريكي جو بارد يامل الرئيس
الفرنسي في ان تسهم هذه الزياره في الدفع
مساعيه الدبلوماسيه الراميه لوضع حد للحرب
في اوكرانيا وايضا الدفاع عن وجهه النظر
الفرنسيه الرافده للنزعه الحمائيه
الامريكيه على كل في اخبار الظاهره ولكن
بعد قليل
انيته يجري يقول محدثاته بشان تهديد الصين
لتايوان
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره كشف
تقرير صادر عن فايننشيل تايمز ان اعضاء في
حلف شمال الاطلسي ناتو عقدوا اول مناظره
مخصصه حول تايوان في سبتمبر الماضي ذكرت
الصحيفه ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تشجع اعضاء النيترو لابناء المزيد من
الاهتمام حياه للتهديدات الصينيه
المتزايده باتجاه تايوان الان الى هذا
التقرير عن مصر وفي بلد تعداده 100 مليون
نسمه بشكل الاقتصاد المصري طبعا غير
الرسمي او الاقتصاد الموازي حوالي 60% من
حجم الاقتصاد الرسمي مصر تفقد مبلغا ضخما
جدا بسبب عدم سدادها هؤلاء للضرائب ولكن
في نفس الوقت يوفر هذا الاقتصاد الموازي
فرص عمل للملايين ما هي سبل استدراج
اقتصاب الظل الى النور التفاصيل في هذا
الدقيق
كل من يتعامل في الاسواق المصريه دون ان
يكون مسجلا لدى الحكومه او يدفع ضرائب
يكون منتميا للاقتصاد غير الرسمي الامر
ينسحب على الباعه الجاهلين او على العمال
الذين يعملون كافراد بالاجر اليوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان ينضم اليهم من يقومون ببعض
اعمال الزراعه او التصنيع البسيط او حتى
سائق التوك توك هذه المركبه التي بدات
الحكومه المصريه مؤخرا في اصدار تراخيص
لها في بعض المحافظات حتى تخرج من الظل
الى النور احمد احد السائقين الذين لم
يرخصوا مركبتهم بعد على الوظيفه
التعبان كنت ما طلعتش اصلا مش مترخص وكده
بردك عامل صعوبه ما اقدرش اطلع بيه بره
وكده اشتغل بس في قلب منطقتي بس في تكاتك
بس في الجيزه بترخص بس هي هنا في القاهره
الترخيص عالي قوي دلوقتي اصلا فاهمني على
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعيه هناك الاف من من
يبيعون منتجات عن طريق توصيلها للمنازل
وهددت الدوله بملاحقتهم كما طلبت من صانع
المحتوى كذلك تسجيل انفسهم لدى السلطات
المصريه لدفع الضرائب الدكتوره داليا
بركات تشرح سبب تفضيل الملايين للعمل
بعيدا عن الاضواء اول حاجه بيفكر فيها
فكره الضرائب مفهوم النظام الضريبي ده
بالنسبه له بعبع انا ايش عرفني هيفردوا
علي غريبه عامله ازاي ممكن ضرائب بيكون
بتتقدر بشكل جذافي اكثر من اللي انا الدخل
اللي بيدخل لي همم الخوف من البيروقراطيه
والاجراءات التكلفه او العيب ان انا برده
همم عشان اروح لها واعمل الاجراءات دي
دراسته درها لرئاسه الوزراء قدرت ان 60%
من حجم الاقتصاد المصريه دوره بالتوازي في
مسار غير رسمي فلا يسدد ضرائب ولكن في نفس
الوقت يوفر فرص عمل للملايين فما السبي
اقناع هؤلاء بامساك الدفاتر
ندي له حوافز نشوف الدول المتقدمه زي
الصين سنغافوره عملوا ايه هناك هنشجعكم
على التصدير هنصدر لكم منتجاتكم وهنروج
اكثر لمنتجاتكم فانا لما احس ان انا داخلي
هيزيد بشكل كبير فاكيد بالنسبه لي اللي
انا طبعا اساهم واللي انا ادخل وانضم
الاقتصاد الرسمي وجوده الاقتصاد غير
الرسميه يحرم الموازنه من حصيله ضريبيه
تقدر بنحو 400 مليار جنيه والتي يمكن ان
تغطي ما يقرب من 85% من اجمالي العجز تامر
نصره العربيه القاهره
مشاهدينا كما تشاهدون على العوازل الانباء
تتحدث عن وفاه الرئيس الصيني السابق جانك
زمن طبعا كان له ظهور قبل فتره قصيره خلال
مؤتمر الحسبه الحاكم واثار هذا ظهور
الكثير من
التساؤلات حول وضعه ان كان على المستوى
الاجتماعي او على المستوى الصحي على كلن
الان الى الموجز الرياضي مع الزميل محمد
القناص
[موسيقى]
مدرب يعني عنده خبره كبيره وعمل مع
المنتخبات وايضا وصلهم الى كاس العالم
واخرها 2018 المغرب همم
الطريقه الايجاز يدير فيها المنتخب انا
اشوف ان عقلانيه ومنطقيه
اللاعبين اللي يلعبوا مع التصفيات الى
الان متمسك فيهم وهمم لغه الحوار معهم همم
يعني احس انها مرتاح لها هو كمدرب
اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله يعود المنتخب
السعودي الى استاد الوسائل الذي شهد
الانتصار التاريخيه امام الارجنتين هذه
المره لخوض المواجهه الحاسمه امام المنتخب
المكسيكي الاخضر سيصل هذا اللقاء وهو
يواجهه معضله الغيابات رغم تعافي رياض
شراحيلي الا ان رينارد يفتقده خدمات محمد
البريكي اصابه وعدد الاله المالكي بسبب
الايقاف وهو الذي كان فقد خدمات القائد
سلمان الفرج والمدافع ياسر الشهراني
للاصابه في مباراه الارجنتين
واكد اندريس جوار دادو نجمه منتخب المكسيك
جاهزيته لمواجهه السعوديه ويعوده بورداته
الذي يشاركه للمره الخامسه في المونديال
على اي تواجد في تشكيلته امام الاخضر
وفي مباراه اخرى يبحث فيها الطرفان عن
تاكيد احقيتهما وحج مقعد في دوري 16 يلتقي
منتخب الارجنتين
مباريات المجموعه الثالثه ايضا المنتخب
الارجنتيني يحتاج الى الفوز لضمان التاهل
بشكل مباشر او سيكفيه التعادل بشرط عدم
فوز المنتخب السعودي وسيكون هدف ميسي
والرفاقه والانتصار بكل تاكيد لاثبات
جدارتهم بالترشح اللي لقب كاس العالم
للمقابل سيحتاج منتخب بولندا الى التعادل
كعقل الاحتمال للوصول الى الدوري المقبل
وعلى استاد المدينه التعليميه يتشبث منتخب
تونس باله في التاهل الى دور المقبل عندما
يواجه حامل اللقب المنتخب الفرنسي ويملك
نسور قرطاج نقطه واحده فيما ضمن منتخب
فرنسا التاهله الى الدور الثاني
في كره القدم
كل الثقه وكل التحفيظ مش حقه نتيجه
ايجابيه ان شاء الله نكون موافقين اهم شيء
المعركه الاخيره بحول الله بشرف
مشاهده كريمه بخير تحدثت مع بنزيما بعد
مغادرته ووضعه سيء ويحتاج الوقت من اجل
الشفاء مواجهه تونس لن تكون سهله سيلعبون
بكل قوه من اجل تحقيق الفوز والتاهل لكننا
سنخوض المباراه بجوده كبيره رغم ضمان
التاهل الى دور السته عشر
المنتخب
النهائي لاول مره منذ نسخه 2006 عندما
يلاقي المنتخب الدنماركي ويحتل الكنغر
الاستراليه المركز الثاني بثلاث نقاط
بينما تحتل الدنمارك المركز الثالث بنفطه
متقدمه على من سوريا قرطه اهداف
[موسيقى]
على منتخب وانجلترا الى دوري 16 في صداره
المجموعه الثانيه بعد ان ظفر بدرب المملكه
المتحده على حساب الجار ويلز بثلاثه اهداف
من دون مقابل شوط المباراه الاول انتهى من
دون اهداف او مطلع الثاني سجل ماركوس
راشفورد الهدف الاول لمنتخب بلاده من ركله
حره بعدها بدقيقه اضافه فيلديني الهدف
الثاني للمنتخب الانجليزي وفي منتصف الشوط
الثاني اضافر الثالث لانجلترا والهدف
الثاني الشخصي له وتضرب انجلترا موعد مع
السنغال جدا جدا
[تصفيق]
اما الامريكان فحسموا التاهلات ثانيا في
المجموعه بفوزهم على منتخب ايران بهدف من
دون مقابل ضمن المجموعه ذاتها الهدف سجله
كريستيان بيلزيتش قبل نهايه الشوط الاول
في مباراه نالت كثيره من الانتباه حول
العالم باسباب غير رياضيه لترفع امريكا
التي ضربت موعد معه هولندا في الدوري
المقبل رصيدها الى خمس نقاط خلف انجلترا
يتجمد رصيده ايران عنده ثلاث نقاط لتود
بدوره ضامنا منتخب هولندا تاهله الى
الدوري المقبل عن المجموعه الاولى بعد
فوزه على نظيره القطري بهدفين من دون
مقابل في ختام المباريات المجموعه احرزاء
كودي جاك بو هدفه هولندا الاول في الدقيقه
الخامسه والعشرين قبل ان يضيف فرانك دي
يونج الهدف الثاني في الدقيقه في التاسعه
والاربعين يرتفع رصيد المنتخب هولندا الى
70 نقاط تصدر بها قمه المجموعه الاولى
بينما بقي رصيد وقطر خاليا من النقاط بعد
ما تلقى منتخبنا الخساره الثالثه
ورافق منتخب السنغال الهولنديين كثاني
المجموعه الى الدوري المقبل بفوزه بهدفين
مقابل هدف على الاكوادور في ختام دور
المجموعات على استاد خليفه الدولي سجل
للسنغال اسماعيل سار من ركله الجزاء في
الدقيقه الرابعه والاربعين واذل الاكوادور
النتيجه عبر كايسيدو في الدقيقه الثامنه
والستين قبل ان يهدي القائد كليدو كليباري
طريقه السنغال الهدف الفوز والعبور في
الدقيقه الثانيه
في المركز الثاني اودعت
[تصفيق]
كانت هذه ابرز واخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه يا امان الله
[موسيقى]
الله الفريق بصراحه
يعني بصراحه بيلعبوا وعندهم يعني البنيه
الجسمانيه قويه رغم انكسار المكسيك ولكن
زي ما ردوا
طيب الذكر
بسرعه في الالتحام غير يعني غير شوف قصير
بس انه يطلع معك بتجنن حتى في الارتقاء
يطلعوا ما شاء الله يعني فهمم يعني احسن
طريقه معاهم
[موسيقى]
تلعب بحظر صراحه لانه صراع وتناقلون
الكبار بسرعه يعني
[موسيقى]
اللاعب السعودي السابق والمحلل الرياضي
دكتور تركي العواد اهلا بك دكتور تركي
اسمح لي انا ابدا بالاخضر اليوم ماذا
نتوقع
والله
بهذه المرحله ونفس الوضع
كان في 94 وكنا مباراه الاخيره ومباراه
الثالثه نحتاج الفوز للتاهل فعلا هذا ما
حدث لذلك دائما المنتخب في المواجهات
الكبيره يظهر بشكل كبير لذلك نتوقع مباراه
قويه مباراه يعني تليق بسمعه المنتخبين
واتوقع المنتخب السعودي قادر وشفنا يعني
همم
تكسب بالرغبه الاكبر واعت من قبل اكبر
للفوز وانهاء دوري المجموعات بالتاهل يعني
حتى المباراتين الماضيه منتخب السعودي
يقدم مستوى جيد اذا يقدر يبني على
المباراتين الماضيه تصورنا قادر على
التاهل ليس سهل لكل تاكيد واحد من افضل 20
منتخب على مستوى العالم وقدم حتى
المباراتين اللي قدمه امام الارجنتين
دقيقه هو اصلا المنتخب الارجنتيني
والمباراه الاولى مع المنتخب البولندي كان
المباراه متكافله لكنه المجموعه الاربعه
فرق يعني صعبه جدا وقبل تبدا بطوله احنا
بنقول هذه كانت هي المجموعه الحديديه لذلك
هذا
الصعوبه حتى الجميع ممكن يتاهل والجميع
ممكن يخرج همم بصعوبه فعلا مجموعه مقارنه
المجموعات الاخرى
شكرا جزيلا لك وكل
الى ناصر الان واخبار الظهيره الاقتصاديه
ناصر تفضل
لنلقي نظره وتحديث ارقام التداولات في
جلسه اليوم
بعض الارتفاعات بدات تزداد نوعا ما لكن
تبقى محدوده منذ الصباح كان هناك حاله من
الاستقرار والهدوء على بورصات المنطقه همم
طبعا هناك عدد من الاحداث الهامه التي
تراقبها بدايه على صعيد اسواق النفط هناك
اجتماع اوبك يوم الاحد الذي كان حضوريا في
فيينا والان اصبح عبر الانترنت الفيديو عن
بعد ومن المتوقع بالتالي ان تبقي كلاس
سياسه الانتاج كما هي ترقبا للحدث المهم
ايضا يوم الاثنين الخامس من ديسمبر الذي
من المفترض ان تفرض فيه او يفرض فيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي الجوله السادسه من
العقوبات على روسيا التي تشمل حظر استيراد
الخام الروسي عبر الناقلات البحريه ووضع
سقف سعري على على تلك الصادرات همم
الروسيه من قبل مجموعه السبع لكن حتى الان
لم يصل الجميع على توافق حول هذا السقف
السعري اسعار النفط على ارتفاع طفيف اليوم
عند ال 84$ للبرميل طبعا اسعار النفط كانت
قد فقدت مكاسبها التي كانت قد سجلتها
السنه نعود الى التداولات ال- همم الاسهم
في المنطقه همم مؤشر السوق السعوديه
الحاليه عند ال 10,000 و750 همم
شهد تراجعات على مدار الاسابيع الاربعه
الماضيه اقوى باور طبعا همم ستقوم همم
انشاء اكبر محطه اا فوتو ضوئيه بي بي في
منطقه الش- شرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
والتي تبلغ قدرتها 2 جيجا وات همم طبعا
بالمشاركه مع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه تم
توقيع عقد الشراء مع شركه شراء الطاقه
المستقله السعوديه العقده 35 سنه وتقدر
قيمه العقد بمليار و750 مليون دولار شركه
جاهز ت- تستحوذ بالكامل على شركه شيفز
مقابل 650 مليون ريال نصفها ستدفع كاش
والنصف الاخر عبر زياده راس مال واصدار
اسهم لمساهمي شركه همم شافز هذه كانت
مشاهدينا وقفتنا مع الاسواق المنطقه نعود
الان من جديد الى استديوهاتنا في الرياض
ميسون
ناصر
لا افغانستان الان حيث حل شتاء الثامن تحت
سلطه طالبان في وقت اعلنت فيه الامم
المتحده ان 79% من الشعب الافغاني لا
يستطيعون الوصول الى معدات التدفئه في
الشتاء الحالي دعونا نتابع
يعيش معه اسرته على بعد امتار من قصر
الرئاسه العاصمه كابول في هذه المنازل
الطينيه المتواضعه التي لا تقي برد الشتاء
اسرته بلزارين تعكس الحياه في الكره
الافغانيه التي يعيش فيها معظم الشعب
الافغاني
يقولذرين انه هو اطفاله السته جمع
البلاستيكه وقطعا من الحطب في الشوارع
للتدفئه في هذا الشتاء
وفصل الشتاء سوف يمر علينا بدون اي وسائل
تدفئه كم ترى هناك قليل من البلاستيك
وليست عندنا وسائل اخرى للتدفئه
عائله فاطمه هي الاخرى التي تعيش في
العاصمه كابول قتل زوجها في عمليه تفجيريه
وهي كفيفه لديها خمسه من الاطفال الصغار
تقول ان جيرانها ساعدوها لتشتري كميه من
الفحم لا تكفيهم لاسبوع تشح بالقليل منه
لتدفئه اطفالها
الجيران يساعدوننا احيانا ببعض الحطب
واحيانا كثيره لا ونحن في اكثر الاوقات لا
نحصل على التدفئه كيس واحد من الفحم لا
يكفي بالنسبه لطول الشتاء اما الطبقه
المتوسطه والتي توصف بالطبقه الثريه في
افغانستان فانها تعتمد على وسائل التدفئه
مريحه لا تخرج دخانا ولا تحدث ازعاجا
تشتغل اكثر بالحطب وبعضها بالوقود ولكننا
نفقاتها باهظه
اصول الشتاء طويل
جدا
ونقوم بها في حرق الحطب ونشكر الله على
هذه الوسائل فان الشتاء في افغانستان قارس
جدا وقد اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
المساعدات الانسانيه
ان 79% من سكان افغانستان يعيشون في ملاجئ
مؤقته ومنازل الشبه مدمره هذا الشتاء فصل
الشتاء في افغانستان بارد وممطر مليء
بالمصاعد في وقت تحذر المؤسسات الامميه من
الشيطان الحالي سيكون تحديا اضافيا
لتحديات اليوميه للشعب الافغاني عبد
المنذر العربيه كابول
ايه ده المشاهدين كما ذكرنا بالعواجل توفي
الزعيم الصيني السابق جيان زمن طبعا هو
ادخل البلاد في مرحله تحول من نهايه
الثمانينات الى مطلع الالفيه اليوم
الاربعاء توفي عن عمر وصل الى 96 عاما انا
هذا على ما ذكرت وكاله شونخ والرسميه
للانباء وقد تولى جونغ زمن السلطه بعد قمع
احتجاجات ساحه تينانين وقاد الصين اكثر
بلدان العالم تعدادا للسكان لتصبح قوه لا
يستهان بها على الساحه الدوليه هذا وقد
دخلت ثمان طائرات حربيه صينيه واربعه
طائرات روسيه الى منطقه الدفاع الجوي في
كوريا الجنوبيه وفقه وكاله ايون هاب ليقوم
جيش كوريا الجنوبيه باتخاذ اجراءات
تكتيكيه ردا على اقتحام المجال الجوي على
كلن ايضا خبر طبي ايجابي جدا قال علماء ان
عقار لمرض الزهايمر الذي تنتجه شركه ايساي
اليابانيه وشركه بايوجين الامريكيه نجح
خلال التجارب السريريه في ابطاء التدهور
المعرفي والوظيف لدى المصابين بالمراحل
المبكره من المرض هو ما يحتمل ان يكون
فوزا نادرا في هذا المجال
[موسيقى]
مواعيد مشاهدين الخبر العاجل اليوم توفي
الزعيم الصيني السابق والذي ادخل البلاد
في مرحله تحول من نهايه الثمانينات الى
مطلع الالفيه اليوم
الاربعاء عن 96 عاما على مذكره وكالته
الرسميه للانباء وقد تولى السلطه بعد قمع
احتجاجات ساحه مين وقاده الصين اكثر بلدان
العالم تعدادا للسكان قادها لتصبح قوه لا
يستهان بها طبعا على الساحه الدوليه
وبهذا الخبر نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
اخبار الظهيره نلتقي غدا واخبار جديده
مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]